pour le reste pour le reste il y a une
très belle dynamique en faveur de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je suis moi-même
impressionné chaque jour par cette
dynamique et je pense qu'elle ne peut
que progresser d'ici d'ici le le premier
tour et j'ajouterai un dernier élément
je voudrais m'adresser aux électeurs de
Benoît hont et et aux électeurs
socialistes je respecte leurs candidats
évidemment cela dit il y a aujourd'hui
une chance de faire en sorte que la
gauche soit au deuxème tour de
l'élection présidentielle cette chance
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon et donc je
pense que le vote nécessaire c'est le
vote pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est la
première fois depuis le début de la
campagne qu'on se dit que la gauche
peut-être
de termine alors sa
campagne de rater cette occasion là et
donc je les invite à voter massivement
pour jeanlch d le prier tour